[Music]
imagery like in paintings
dramatic storylines like in literature
and emotional music like an opera
[Music]
contemporary computer games reach new
artistic heights to many the combination
of different art forms reminds one of
release at vogner's nineteenth-century
ideal of the all-embracing work of art
developed the concept of the total work
of art with the intention that the set
music acting dancing all of the
individual components that play an
important role in a theatrical
performance should merge to get the
perfect results no game has met this
high goal yet but in some areas they've
certainly come a long way
the life is strange Ceres brilliantly
captures the drama of growing up in
horizon zero dawn the fictitious
landscape functions as a gigantic
backdrop that can be explored by the
players it's a world populated by
mysterious robotic creatures in many
video games the soundtrack plays an
important role
like in journey the minimalistic game
portrays the progression of life
[Music]
so-called comp games can only be played
with two players in a way out
players lead characters through a prison
break-out playing feels like a dance for
two Lebanese Swedish director Yosef
Arnaz is the games developer he wrote
the screenplays for a number of
successful Swedish films but to him game
design is the highest form of creativity
I love games I love how they are I mean
and I think there's a big opportunity
also from creatively to do something
that really hasn't been done before I
mean movies are fun too but it's a
different thing and I think games will
have a way greater impact in the future
then films will ever have actually the
director of Berlin's computer game
Museum is andreas Langham he's an expert
on the cultural value of gaming
he believes that through their
interactivity video games offer many new
possibilities in comparison to the
classic media of storytelling the
interactivity of computer games allows
players to take on different
perspectives experience various things
and of course to influence the course of
the story itself but the interactivity
can also be a hurdle as each player has
the power to influence the plot too many
limitations can ruin the gaming
experience telling a complex story is
not so easy you can't just write a story
like a movie the movie you can control
everything more here you have to know
like when this scene will come in and
when did this fits and what will you
gameplay be here what will you play
normally vogner expert Autobahn box
Forte isn't gaming but does the
professor see similarities to vogner's
total work of art
clover and leaning cinta I believe there
are some parallels when you consider the
soundtrack the aesthetic value of the
images and the possibility of variation
which are all elements that also play a
role in Farnaz total work of art and I
can imagine that if Bogner were
confronted with video games they would
fascinate him games have the potential
to combine different art forms not every
game developer will create a universal
piece of art right away but expectations
of aesthetic standards are sir